what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and right now the future
of Spider-Man is looking very very
bright in both universes in the Sony
universe and I specify the live action
universe and also for Tom Holland's
Peter Parker in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now fans have really been
loving Spider-Man in the MCU but Sony
does seemingly have a plan that's
honestly looking to be pretty dang good
if they pull it off the right way and
they've just pulled off something truly
amazing Spider-Man across the
spider-verse if you haven't seen that
movie yet please go see it it is an
Amazing Spider-Man movie and Sony
basically has plans to do that in live
action form in fact if you missed the
news the other day Sony did come out and
confirm they are indeed working on a
live action Miles Morales movie this was
confirmed by Amy Pascal an executive
producer who said they're working on
that right now they're also working on a
spider Woman animated movie a
live-action Spider Woman movie as well
and just overall they are working on
their spider-verse and if they pull it
off the way that they want to it's gonna
be what US Spider-Man fans have been
waiting for which is just super exciting
to think about she also offered an
update for Spider-Man 4 and Tom Holland
has recently offered an update for
Spider-Man 4 as well but what's really
really interesting is that the contract
between Sony and Marvel Studios over the
rights for Spider-Man and Spider-Man
characters has recently been shared
online two different versions and it
looks like the contract kind of gives us
an idea of what Marvel Studios is trying
to do with their Spider-Man and the MCU
and their villain for Spider-Man so a
lot to break down in this video and if
you're new be sure to subscribe and
leave a comment because that enters you
in our giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item and we pick a winner at
the end of each month also check out our
patreon website and Discord board will
link those in the pin comment down below
now speaking of Sony's spider-verse plan
their own Spider-Man universe that they
have going on right now with movies such
as Venom morbius Madame web all of these
movies are going to start connecting
maybe not so much venom and morbius
since Venom 3 is going to be the last
Venom film and morbius was morbius but
Madam Webb is the movie that is supposed
to start off the live action Spider-Man
Multiverse for Sony and from there their
plans are pretty great but let's start
off by talking about what might be a key
part to their plan and that is the live
action Spider-Man they're going to have
in their Universe this could be Miles
Morales in our video breakdown where we
talked about the announcement that they
are developing a live-action Miles
Morales we asked the question of which
universe is this live-action Miles
Morales going to be in is he going to be
a part of the Sony spiderverse or is he
going to be in the MCU we know that Tom
Holland is pretty much done after the
next three Spider-Man films and of
course his team up films as well could
Miles Morales go to the MCU and take a
spot or is Miles Morales going to be the
main Spider-Man in the spider-verse for
Sony and it looks like that one is going
to be their plan have Miles Morales be
the main Spider-Man in the spider-verse
most likely due to the fact that they do
want to have some distinction between
their universe and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now I do think that there is
going to be a Peter Parker Spider-Man
that shows up in the spider-verse at
some point in time but he just may not
be the main focus in fact I don't think
any one particular Spider-Man is going
to be a main main focus I think they are
going to introduce different variants of
Spider-Man and then have them all come
together in a very big movie in fact I
was waiting to make this video until I
actually saw Spider-Man across the
spider-verse in theaters just so I knew
everything that was going on and what's
interesting is that the movie did show
us that the original Spider-Man films
with Toby Maguire and Andrew Garfield's
Amazing Spider-Man films are Canon to
their animated Multiverse so Sony's
spider-verse is huge and even writer of
across the spider-verse Phil Lord said
that they actually saved a lot more
Spider-Mans for the next film Beyond the
spider-verse which we're thinking could
tie into Sony's live-action Universe
since it is beyond their current
spider-verse and it makes us wonder what
they have planned for their live-action
spider-verse and we kind of essentially
know what they're doing they're going to
mimic across the spider-verse they're
going to set up many different
characters both heroes and villains with
films like Madam Webb and Craven the
Hunter and then they're going to have a
huge Avengers end game slash Avengers
Secret Wars level event where they
basically have their Multiverse their
spider-verse Collide and a huge event
which has been rumored to be a spider
get an event and this event in the
comics was essentially a secret Wars of
Spider-Man a bunch of different variants
of Spider-Man get pulled into one
universe and they all up to fight
together to save the universe and the
Multiverse itself and if this is Sony's
plan awesome that is what we want to see
if the films are done correctly if the
mile Morales film is done right if
Madame Webb is done right if a new Peter
Parker Spider-Man film was done right
this is what we want to see and
hopefully they can pull it off if they
are taking a lot of inspiration from
across the spider-verse and into the
spider-verse let's hope they can use
similar teams as far as the story is
concerned to make their live-action
spider-verse amazing and let's not
forget that they did confirm that Amy
Pascal does consult with Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige on each of their
Spider-Man projects which is an awesome
thing that they didn't really do before
so hopefully their new spiderverse is
about to be a lot better and Tom Holland
Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is about to be a lot better as
well as we have confirmations from Sony
and Tom Holland himself stating that
they have been having discussions they
have been doing the pre-development for
Spider-Man 4. it's official it has been
happening however due to the wga strike
the writer's Guild strike they are
postponing those meetings until the
strike is done but this most likely
means that they have come to a new
contract agreement with Tom Holland
otherwise they wouldn't be talking about
the fourth Spider-Man movie already now
we have heard reports that the deal has
been done for a little bit now for a few
months and if you don't know the
reported deal is this three new
Spider-Man movies so Spider-Man 4 5 and
then six two big team up movies which is
going to be Avengers the King Dynasty
and of course Avengers Secret Wars and
then one more team up project we're
unsure at this point if it's a movie or
a show now what's really interesting is
like I mentioned we have recently seen
the contracts for Sony and Marvel's deal
for the Spider-Man characters now there
were two that were shown and the latest
one was the 2011 one now this was before
Marvel Studios had the rights to use
Peter Parker Spider-Man in the MCU but
what's really interesting is it talks
about some special Spider-Man characters
and this could give us a hint as to what
Marvel Studios is planning to do with
the route of Spider-Man because it
involves Kingpin this is what the older
contract says about kingpin's characters
and some other characters and sharing
the rights to have them on screen
whether in a movie or TV show and just
so you know spe means Sony Pictures
Entertainment one section of the
contract reads non-exclusive to spe spe
and Marvel share the following and in
quotes it says Kingpin and related
characters it then goes on to say that
Marvel's use of Kingpin is restricted to
use in connection with Daredevil and
other characters with which he appeared
prior to 9 15 2011. so Marvel Studios
has been sharing the rights to Kingpin
so Kingpin has been shared by Marvel and
Sony for some time now but there is a
stipulation that kind of states that if
Marvel Studios does use Kingpin he kind
of has to be related somewhat to a
Spider-Man project or a daredevil
project now keep in mind we don't know
the new contract for this but we do know
that Marvel Studios has been using
Kingpin in the MCU now it does seem like
like the rules have changed just a
little bit because Kingpin was used in
the Hawkeye series now this was really
kind of just a setup for him being the
big bad of the street level Avengers
he's going to appear in Echo then
Daredevil and it would seem the big plan
is to eventually have him go up against
Spider-Man since they are sharing the
rights for Spider-Man still it would
make sense that they would have him go
up against the other character or one of
the other characters that they have also
been splitting the rights with Kingpin
and since he appeared in Hawkeye is
appearing in Echo and appearing in
Daredevil I'm gonna say that eventually
we're gonna see him go up against
Spider-Man and this could be the big
plan for Marvel now they could have him
go up against Kingpin and Spider-Man 4
and him stick around and eventually take
on an actual Sinister Six with Kingpin
being the leader at least that's what we
hope for either way Kingpin and
Spider-Man are destined to meet sometime
relatively soon in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now what was also kind of
interesting about this contract is that
it says there are requirements when it
comes to producing the movies and shows
specifically state that each picture so
movie must have an all-in budget of not
less than 75 million it must qualify for
a PG-13 rating and have an initial
domestic theatrical release of no less
than 2 000 screens so this basically
says you cannot make a mediocre low
budget Spider-Man or Spider-Man
character film meaning you can't just
bust out another morbius film that only
has the budget of like 25 million or 50
million or so basically each Spider-Man
project that both Marvel and Sony do has
to be big which is really great when
you're talking about kind of some of
these main Spider-Man characters that
will be executed well but is also kind
of bad when it comes to movies like
morbius and again keep in mind that was
in 2011 the contracts have definitely
changed by then and we know that Marvel
kind of has a little bit more control
over Spider-Man in their MCU now however
it is just looking like it's only
Spider-Man and Kingman in that Marvel
still has control over for the most part
Sony still has the control over the
other Spider-Man characters but it is
kind of cool to see how they negotiated
with each other in the past so let us
know all of your thoughts about both
Spider-Man Miles Morales and Peter
Parker Spider-Man in the comments down
below what do you think Sony should do
with their live-action spider-verse
leave your thoughts down below also
don't forget to subscribe and leave a
comment to enter our giveaway if you
want to further support the channel you
can check out our patreon account you
can also check out our website and our
Discord server which we'll link down
below and of course you can always
follow us on Instagram and Twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf